[Musique]
le sens négatif par lequel
nous parlons de réfugiés migrants
issus de l'immigration en général est
autour des affiches et aujourd'hui
sur l'opposition entre nous et eux
aux Italiens la population italienne
avant même les étrangers
[Musique]
bref, on dit que les femelles s'élevaient
fausses nouvelles
il y a toujours eu dans un sens est
vrai qui pas dans le processus aujourd'hui ont
des caractéristiques diffusées à travers
internet avec quelques spécifications avec un
production en série avec une tension
vers la viralité de ceux qui les produisent
le sommet de l'union européenne et des nombreux
déposer ses formations est une vérification que
de nombreux sites Web basés sur l'actualité
[Musique]
Turin